[Música]
en primera plana
braulio moro
[Música]
bienvenidos a en primera plana una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español donde damos la seguimiento a
la actualidad internacional los
electores brasileños irán a las urnas el
mes de octubre pero el presidente
saliente ya y el bolsón aro a des vuelto
a atacar al sistema electoral haciendo
temer que podría no aceptar la derrota
en esas elecciones cuál es la situación
en brasil a pocos meses de las
elecciones presidenciales que tanto
cambio la sociedad brasileña durante el
gobierno de jair bolsonaro cómo están
las fuerzas de oposición y en particular
la del principal candidato ex presidente
lula da silva para hablar de ello
tenemos como invitados en nuestro
estudio a thomas ekman doctor en teoría
política deseas por especialista en
brasil buenos dias tomás bueno el día de
braulio un gusto tener con nosotros
estar también con nosotros práctico el
periodista del diario francés le figaro
responsable de la rúbrica en
latinoamérica bienvenido patrick gracias
es un gusto tenemos igualmente a él
cierra malo jefe del servicio de brasil
de radio france internacional mucho
gusto de tener con nosotros leo gracias
la invitación y desde ríos nos acompaña
nuestro corresponsal marcos moreno bien
hola buenos días desde el río de janeiro
hace calor aunque ya es otoño aquí
bienvenido elecciones en brasil
transición o ruptura institucional
estamos en primera plana
la campaña por la elección presidencial
cuyos protagonistas principales serán
sin duda el propio ya y revolucionario y
el ex presidente lula da silva iniciará
sólo en el mes de agosto pero hay que
decir que ya ahora el país está en
ebullición política vamos a ver lo que
dicen algunas portadas de la prensa
brasileña el diario folha de sao paulo
titula partidos ven riesgos de golpe
bolsonaro y las autoridades callan la
revista istoé exhibe en portada al
presidente de otra derecha acompañado
del título en el límite de la ruptura
institucional
otra revista bella se dedica a lo que
son los presidenciables formulan
estrategias para llegar al electorado
joven thomas la sociedad brasileña ha
sufrido una serie de cambios en los
pasados cuatro años notablemente en lo
político en lo económico en lo social en
lo ecológico si hubiera que retener una
sola de las reformas que se han
realizado en estos cuatro años que
pueden ser determinantes en la selección
de estructuras cual que tendría usted
sin duda hubo muchísimas reformas y
cambios en la política brasileña pero
creo que más importante que hablar de
las reformas institucionales que hubo
como privatización eso no es pensar a
los cambios que representa el presidente
por sonar o para las instituciones de la
democracia liberal en verdad porque no
podemos normalizar lo que hace el
gobierno involucionar o lo que ha hecho
este presidente porque lo que vimos en
brasil en los últimos cuatro años son
ataques constantes amenazas a la
democracia liberal y creo que si tenemos
que elegir entre todas esas amenazas
porque hay ataques al tribunal
constitucional
en muchos órganos de control pero el más
el más importancia creo yo es la
presencia de la vuelta de regreso de los
militares a la vida propia la
regeneración mente
porque evolucionar william hace amenazas
de golpes porque no está bien en las en
las encuestas para movilizar su
militancia sin duda pero me gustaría
decir unas cosas que hay un filósofo
español muy conocido que decía que el
poder es mucho más una cuestión
es mucho menos una cuestión de puño que
de posaderas lo que pasa es que personar
puede intentar hacer un golpe pero creo
que es muy difícil para el de que
suceda bien este golpe entonces es más
el papel del personaje los ataques a las
instituciones que las reformas en sí
mismas el yo en este caso qué piensas tú
efectivamente hay que pensar más en el
personaje o hay reformas que han marcado
sustancialmente en estos pasados cuatro
años a la sociedad la cila en realidad
la única reforma que ha logrado hacer es
la reforma de las pensiones no que que
lo hizo en su primer año de mandato pero
las otras reformas que promueve prometió
todavía no logró hacerlas por completo
por ejemplo la reforma tributaria para
simplificar los impuestos de hembras y
las que fueran administrativa también
por ahí para dar más dinamismo a la
máquina pública todavía no has logrado
entonces lo que prometió del punto de
vista económico todavía la gente espera
los empresarios no el mundo económico
espera de todo más de esto pero lo que
marcó todavía de estos cuatro años de
ahí de bolsonaro fue
este de ataques que se refirió tomar
también que en un personaje quien no le
gusta me parece que no le gusta esta
vida democrática y con ataques repetidos
contra el congreso nacional también
contra las instituciones y también una
gestión catastrófica de la pandemia
también no esto no va a marcar muchísimo
su gobierno hasta hasta las elecciones
creo desde octubre vamos a llegar a
estas elecciones en una situación de
debilitamiento de la economía brasileña
no sólo por causa de la cob y sino
también por la mala gestión que ha
tenido lugar el gobierno afirma haber
recuperado lo que se perdió como
producto interno bruto el año pasado
logró superar oficialmente más del 4 por
ciento del crecimiento no obstante la
inflación está al alza los precios están
subiendo tan sólo en el mes de abril ya
se ha llegado al 10 por ciento patrick
que tanto va a jugar esta situación que
parece fuera de control para el gobierno
sabiendo que estamos a pocos meses de
las elecciones y que es poco probable
que se pueda solucionar en tan pocos
meses esta situación de inflación
galopante
la economía
eso es muy mala actualmente y si el
gobierno dice que puede recuperar algo
no va a recuperar antes de desde seis
meses y con la inflación de 10 por
ciento es una distinción muy grave
porque no hay crecimiento y hay en los
años pasados estaban muy malas
y además hay que ver que
brasil es una economía abierta y tiene
muchas influencias del panorama
económico mundial hay también
una importancia de china que hizo muchas
inversiones en
brasil y que está actualmente en una
situación económica
problemática además se haya destinación
de y que hizo que la economía mundial
tiene una explicación complicada así
parece que las promesas del gobierno
actual de para decir al isi que
también iba a miró a laxe me parece que
no es verdad y que realmente la economía
brasileña es está en nuestra situación
muy mala el geo vuelvo a ti porque
comentarlas hace un instante el tema del
lo que fueron los resultados de la
pandemia toda américa latina ha sido más
ha sido el continente más afectado por
el número de muertes en el caso de
brasil esta gestión oficialmente provocó
medio millón de muertos hay algunos que
hablan de 600.000 más de seiscientos mil
muertos esto le va a pasar cuenta al
presidente bolsas de seguro esto es un
tema que claro que va a estar y la ley
las campañas por qué bolsonaro en todo
este tema desde la pandemia la negó es
un negacionista de la pandemia
pensó que quería abrir la economía que
la economía continuará funcionando
durante la pandemia y mientras tanto la
gente se moría por falta de vacuna que
no hizo tampoco caso para tener la
vacuna lo más pronto posible no hace
esto se quedó a cargo de los
gobernadores locales de buscar vacunas y
otras partes del mundo que hace contacto
con otros países entonces esto lo va el
brasil tuvo como más de 620 mil muertos
por la pandemia entonces una gestión
catastrófica de la pandemia sólo va a
pasar sin duda ninguna ninguna serán dos
temas que van a hablar sus adversarios
políticos porque se dieron cuenta que es
un presidente que no protege no su
población en un momento de crisis
sanitario como lo pasó con la pandemia
entonces su gestión seguro que van a
insistir muchísimo que fue una gestión
de verdad muy catastrófica durante todo
el periodo de la pandemia incluso
empieza a volver algunos casos también
con estas variantes
pero todavía se quedó muy claro que el
presidente no estuve al tanto altura de
esta pandemia de la crisis muy grave
cual es la popular día no obstante del
presidente ya él bolsonaro que sectores
están apoyándole que peso tendrán esos
sectores en las elecciones de octubre
tomás yo quisiera comenzar con usted
concretamente los evangélicos han jugado
un papel fundamental creciente en las
últimas elecciones desde principios del
siglo cómo van a apoyar que peso pueden
tener para hacer eventualmente cannalire
bolsón dar es verdad que personal es muy
fuerte entre los evangélicos pero mismo
entre ellos hoy día
está perdiendo un poco de su popularidad
de su apoyo entonces lo que miramos en
las últimas en los últimos sondeos las
últimas encuestas ejecución aros ya
pierde entre casi todos los grupos
religiosos pero es verdad
el botón bolsonaro es más grande entre
los más ricos y los evangélicos fort muy
importante para que el tiende a los
votos en algunos sectores más pobres
pero al mismo tiempo su situación en los
sondeos en las encuestas es es compleja
es difícil es delicada es difícil para
él ganar ganar
es casi imposible hoy día lo que puedo
intentar hacer es como 30 en los eeuu de
decir que hubo fraude las elecciones que
las elecciones no que lula no que no
etcétera pero esta administración
delicada ya vamos a brasil donde están
nuestros corresponsales marcos moreno
marcos jair bolsonaro ha dado un espacio
a los militares como nunca antes muchos
de sus ministros son o han sido
generales como puede juzgar eso en el
momento de la en el resultado de las
elecciones lo que está en cuestión ahora
mismo no es el resultado de las
elecciones sino la aceptación del
resultado de las elecciones en caso de
que ya el bolsón aro pierda estas
elecciones y ahí es donde entra muy de
una forma muy crítica el ejército porque
ya hay revolucionario ha dicho
claramente que no aceptará una derrota
en estas elecciones y si esto sucede
donde se colocará el ejército que es
sobre todo entre la base del ejército es
más proclive es más favorable
bolsonaro entonces la fuerza del voto de
los militares es grande pero lo que
importa es lo que sucederá después de
los resultados gracias marcos volveremos
contigo en unos instantes más elección
de manera breve hay un sector de la
clase media que votó claramente por jair
bolsonaro gente de los sectores
populares que también votaron con el que
jugaron un papel fundamental en la
destitución de dilma rousseff esta gente
volverá a votar bolsonaro o podrían
cambiar de posición ahora hay mucho que
están
ilusionados con bolt sonar porque muchos
acuerda mos que en 2018 votaron contra
el pp con tele petismo no entonces para
mucha para muchas de esta franja de la
población
bolsonaro fue también es un malo
presidente también no logra hacer los
cambios que por ahí
solía hacer o debería hacer entonces yo
creo que para mucha para mucha gente
bolsonaro no logró hacer cumplir sus
promesas y la gente que está
con un bolsón ar no va a volver volta
para él incluso los que antes estaban
contra el pp con temple tease mo porque
fue una situación muy excepcional
acordamos que en 2018 estaba como el
tema de la baja tono al pp un partido
que estaba rumbo muy colgada a la
corrupción pero y después que también se
cancelaron las
sentencias contra luna no entonces yo
creo que para esta gente no van a muchos
de ellos no van a volver a votar para
personarse esto explica un poco porque
no quiere decir las encuestas pues vamos
a hacer una pequeña pausa en un dos por
tres minutos volvemos aquí en primera
plana estamos hablando sobre brasil
[Música]
enlace del conosur a norteamérica de los
andes' a centroamérica una cita semanal
con los temas más importantes de los
países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
france 24
enlace en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]
liberté égalité actual y t
estamos de regreso aquí en primera plana
estamos hablando de las elecciones de
este año en brasil nos acompañan tomas
sigman doctor en teoría perdón política
deseas pode de parís está también con
nosotros patrick del del diario le
figaro y está el señor rama lo que es el
jefe del servicio brasileño y allá en
río de janeiro está nuestro compañero
marcos moreno marcos quiero comenzar
contigo esta segunda parte ya ir
bolsonaro ha venido cuestionando la
imparcialidad de las instituciones
brasileñas concretamente por ejemplo la
del tribunal supremo electoral ha
cuestionado también a los jefes al
tribunal supremo como percibe la
población este tipo de ataques
lo que pasa es que ya ha ir bolsonaro
durante estos años de legislatura se ha
encargado de deslegitimar el poder
judicial y éste ha respondido de una
forma digamos que partidaria ejerciendo
de una oposición política ausente en el
momento a esto se une que hay
verdaderamente problemas en el poder
judicial de brasil tanto por la cantidad
de leyes que no han sido reformadas en
mucho tiempo como por los procesos es
decir aunque la población no cree que
vaya a haber un fraude en las elecciones
a no ser los seguidores de bolsón aros
que aceptan cualquier precepto que él
diga sí que tampoco hay una confianza
ciega en la justicia en brasil gracias a
los marcos el ceo precisamente con lo
que comenta nuestro corresponsal hay en
río de janeiro al inicio de este
programa hablábamos de lo que dice la
revista bella que habla de un límite en
la ruptura institucional es factible o
es correcto es que lanzan está alerta
que están lanzando la revista de que el
país podría estar en el límite de la
ruptura institucional
evolucionar está intentando todavía
deslegitimar justamente todo el proceso
empezó hace muy hace mucho tiempo desde
el principio de la precampaña electoral
a decir que no va a reconocer el
resultado de las elecciones entonces es
como que prepara la población para algo
que puede significar una ruptura
institucional pero yo creo que en este
momento las respuestas que le dan el
supremo tribunal electo el lector al y
también la sociedad brasileña significa
que las instituciones
en brasil siguen muy fuertes todavía
esto que intenta solucionar yo creo que
no va a lograr
meter miedo en la población y quizás a
intentar un golpe o algo así yo creo que
habla esto y intenta también como
alinearse con los militares a ver cómo
reaccionan los militares también para
ver lo que puede hacer hasta qué punto
hasta qué medida puede tomar pero creo
que las instituciones hoy democráticas
en brasil son fuertes suficientes para
que este tipo de amenazas no lleguen al
cabo ya vamos a hablar de quién aparece
como el favorito para ganar la elección
presidencial del próximo mes de octubre
estamos hablando del ex presidente lula
da silva recordemos brevemente que tras
su segundo mandato fue acusado de
recibir sobornos y fue detenido en abril
de 2018 condenado a 17 años de prisión
estuvo en la cárcel 19 meses finalmente
fue dijéramos absuelto por la justicia y
recién salido una encuesta que le dan
ganador desde la primera vuelta
electoral patrick es cierto que lula es
muy querido en un sector de la población
pero también polariza mucho a la
sociedad brasileña
polariza pero es un hombre de compromiso
no es un chávez
lo que se ve por ejemplo el hijo como
this presente un nombre de derecha
no es un
personaje que divisó a los valencianos
pero ahora parece como como un nombre
que va a calmar y haber conversión al
que quique
que quiera mucho que es un personaje
que puede
amar o
[Música]
al contrario ahora luna parece como una
persona más calma y que puede
desarrollar un compromiso en la
navegación policial thomas es en este en
esta frecuencia en esta lógica que se
tendría que entender la alianza que
acaba de pasar cuando este fue el ex
gobernador de sao paulo geraldo alckmin
que recordemos un feroz opositor a lula
un hombre que se puede considerar de
derecha pero con el que ahora a pasa una
pero para que sea ni más ni menos que el
vicepresidente en caso de que no la gane
las elecciones si de verdad lula intenta
hacer un arco de alianza largo
en verdad toda la izquierda casi toda la
izquierda ya está con él y ahora se
analiza también con esta alianza con
mujer audiencia es verdad fue su
adversario en las elecciones de 2006
pero podemos decir que el tipo de
antagonismo que existía entre lula y
alckmin no es el mismo tipo de
antagonismo que existe entre lula y
bolsonaro porque entre el une al quien
tenemos dos alternativas dentro del
campo democrático ahora con bolsonaro
tenemos al contrario el campo
democrático que va a reunir toda esta
gente de la centroizquierda a la
centroderecha en contra a alguien que es
una amenaza para la democracia liberal
esto en un parlamento que tiene decenas
y decenas de partidos esta alianza con
admin le podría eventualmente garantizar
una mayoría del parlamento el siu es lo
que está buscando lula no hacer un arco
de alianza lo más amplio posible no
justamente para quizás ganar y convencer
los electores para ganar justo en la
primera vuelta no como le dan las
encuestas hasta hoy el tema de brasil es
que hay que decir no es que es muy
complicado tener partido 2 quizás que
tenga la mayoría en el congreso entonces
tiene que hacer muchas alianzas y donde
ahí se puede hacer todo tipo de alianzas
pero lo que está buscando lula incluso a
elegir al kim en un tipo de centro
derecha aunque mucha gente la izquierda
lo contexto muchísimo no le gustó para
nada tener este hombre grado alto como
vicepresidente de células pero a pesar
de hacerlo en ese momento sí y después
también para tener en cuenta que esto
hace parte de una estrategia para tener
el apoyo lo más amplio posible incluso
de la centroderecha donde lula tiene por
ahí menos apoyo pero con personas así
como aliados así también se puede
conquistar la clase por ejemplo de los
empresarios que por ahí me tiene un poco
más de ofrecer la cual con lula entonces
lo que piensa es tener lo más apoyo más
apoyo posible para tener justamente
un congreso que le apoya le apoyará en
el futuro en caso que sea precedente que
él vuelve al palacio del planalto
patrick que estamos a cinco meses de las
elecciones presidenciales que tan
viables que tan creíbles esta encuesta
en la que hacemos referencia que acaba
de publicarse donde se le da una primera
a lula una posible victoria desde la
primera vuelta electoral por más de diez
puntos de ventaja con respecto a el
bolsón al decir ahora la diferencia
entre las encuestas entre lula y
personales es muy grande en 48 y persona
de los 27 así parece difícil que se
puede cambiar la situación y la victoria
de lula
parece seguro porque está en cuesta 48
si contamos también los votos si no
contamos los votos nulos y la extensión
dura puede ganar fácilmente a 50
450 3% que es en un caso excepcional
porque comentábamos antes de iniciar
esta emisión que desde que se creó la
reelección de los años 90 con cardoso
con fernando henrique cardoso el
presidente siempre un presidente cuando
se representa ha ganado las elecciones
toda la verdad eso se pasó tres veces
con cardoso con lula y con dilma
entonces sería una primera vez que un
presidente se presenta para la
reelección y no gana y más que esto lo
que pasa ahora en brasil también es que
muchos candidatos ya en la primera
vuelta decidieron renunciar entonces
tenemos ahora una primera vuelta que se
convierte casi en una segunda vuelta ya
porque tenemos como dos candidatos y
medio tres candidatos y luego meses el
lote es el otro que tiene ahora siete
por ciento el que no está también
entonces finalmente tenemos como lula y
versionar yo ya en la primera vuelta
polarizando el sentido de concentrando
los votos de una parte muy grande del
electorado lo que pasa por tanto es que
por sonar puede ser el primer presidente
de brasil que no gana su reelección y
más que eso puede ser es difícil todavía
tenemos como aún tenemos a seis meses
por las elecciones por puede también
perder en la primera vuelta excepcional
es muy posible porque es que los rechazo
al nombre de personal es muy grande no
es de 58 por ciento de personas que
dicen no bolt no votó involucionado de
ninguna forma y para lula el rechazo más
pequeño 33 por ciento según esta
encuesta entonces es decir que la
posibilidad de lula que lo hagan en la
primera vuelta esto es muy es posible
pero interesante también a ver que la
tercera vía que intentan los otros
partidos políticos de brasil esto no
despega no pero como es por ejemplo se
aparece que es un político muy conocido
es gobernador desde un estado de nuevo
de este ex ministro de lula intenta
buscar ahí y ser el candidato del de la
tercera vía pero no logra y tampoco
logran los otros partidos incluso de
centroderecha que hay varios no hay
varios son decenas de partidos pero no
hay un hombre hoy en día que puede
concurrir y competir contra bolsonaro y
lula entonces por ahí tendremos los dos
candidatos por eso es mucho
mucha gente ya empieza a decir para
hacer por paraná para el voto últil útil
es decir ya dar la victoria abdulá en la
primera vuelta nos quedan un poco menos
de tres minutos hay un tema que perdón
llama mi atención y es lo que ha pasado
en río de janeiro recientemente estando
la matanza de 25 personas
en esa en esa ciudad es la enésima
matanza que se produce por parte de la
policía esto parece que es normalizado
los datos que yo leía son impresionantes
los número de ejecuciones que ha hecho
la policía con torturas y demás y
simplemente en brasil parece que fuera
una cosa localizada exclusivamente a río
de janeiro cuando no es el caso tú más
es verdad en verdad estás tan
normalizado que no se hace hace
muchísimos años que el brasil es uno de
los países más peligrosos y violentos
del mundo
bolsonaro una parte de su victoria
electoral en 2018 se explica también por
la violencia porque él era el tipo que
como se dice que va que va a combatir el
crimen al mismo tiempo lo que pasó es lo
que miramos ahora es que convulsionaron
en el poder se banalizó hay navas todo
esto toda la violencia de la policía
sobre todo entonces tenemos casos de
ejecuciones el caso de torturas de
torturas cosas horribles porque es un
tipo que dice que que se debe
estructurar que la solución para
combatir los criminales es la violencia
policial la brutalidad policial de
excepciones y todo esto entonces es
grave es por eso mismo se esto existía
antes de por sonar es una temática muy
importante que tenemos que cambiar en el
minuto que nos queda patrick en una cosa
que vemos también en estas elecciones es
que esta vez no hay una sola mujer
candidata
cómo se explica esto
si no tengo
por ahí hay una posibilidad que estimo
en tve una asignatura que por ahí está
intentando justamente haberse viabilizan
su nombre es del partido el movimiento
democrático brasileño e intentan no
agregar apoyo para su candidatura pero
tiene 2% de las encuestas entonces
todavía no vamos a tener ni siquiera
como vicepresidente esto es lamentable
se puede decir esto pero se nos quedan
muchos temas en el tintero la situación
en la amazonía otros temas más el tema
de las mujeres como tal los derechos
reproductivos en fin estamos ya llegando
al final de esta en primera plana
agradezco a thomas ekman de barrios
especialista hembra sin su presencia a
patrick weil periodista del diario
francés le figaro a él sión ramal o jefe
del servicio de brasil y allá en río de
janeiro a nuestro compañero omar moreno
a ustedes les damos una nueva cita aquí
la próxima semana en otra en primera
plana